a teenager from Sweden called the voice
of the planet is ready to cross the
Atlantic on a mission to fight climate
change
in this morning's eye on earth we follow
greta toon burg she'll be sailing from
europe to new york to call on world
leaders to protect the environment she
leads a global youth movement and has
been nominated for the Nobel Peace Prize
Roxana Saberi met Greta in her hometown
of Stockholm but at une Berg doesn't
like all this attention I am very very
introvert and shy privately but the 16
year old travels from stage you are not
mature enough to tell it like it is to
stage we know what is at risk and we
will never stop the warning we're
running out of time to tackle climate
change I wanted to act as if the house
was on fire because it is Greta says
having autism gives her the focus and
determination to act her actions started
with a solitary strike outside Sweden's
Parliament last year now she's far from
alone sisters Sarah and Katie O'Callahan
have skipped school to join her on her
weekly strikes since we started a school
striking we've like um we're vegetarian
we don't eat we don't eat dairy no
that's because of Greta yeah yeah we we
don't take the car as much as we used to
it rains yeah so she's really changed
her lives yeah she's changed them for
the better yeah all of these people are
here to see Greta a sign of just how
much her message is resonating here in
Sweden and across Europe now she's
taking her message to the other side of
the Atlantic she's setting sail on a
solar-powered boat bringing a message to
a UN summit in New York the journey
could take two weeks but Greta says she
doesn't fly because of the environmental
impact of air travel
they say they listen to us and now that
is up to to them to prove that if they
have listened how would you rate the
United States climate change efforts not
very high
why not because I mean
the Mishna still rising the u.s.
releases more carbon emissions than any
country except for China Greta wants all
governments to cut emissions in line
with the Paris climate Accord which
President Trump has rejected would you
meet with President Trump why should I
waste time talking to him but judging by
her millions of followers on social
media the climate strikes she's inspired
in the US and across the world
and the number of politicians who want
to hear her speak many people are
listening what can each of us do to
fight climate change to get aware and to
try to understand what is going on what
is happening and also of course I put
pressure on people in power critics
dismissed Greta as alarmist too young
and too inexperienced but she says this
climate crusade must go on
her generation is to have a future for
CBS this morning Roxana Saberi Stockholm
Sweden for an introverted young lady
she's speaking with a very loud voice so
wise beyond her years I heard her speak
in Stockholm in this past summer and the
room was mesmerised by this little girl
because you stand me go okay she's gonna
be a little kid speaking but the words
that came out of her mouth gave
everybody something to think about and
you see that there - yeah and heading
here this is the country to come to you
we are a major contributor to global
warming a major denier of the science of
the rest of the world when I dine on she
makes you think